so every year around the month of
September millions of football disciples
around the world get glued to the TV
screen they scream they holler they
shout they depict debate on why they
believe their sports team their football
team is going to win the Super Bowl that
year and then only one team ends up
winning having said that the game of
football
fundamentally won the most difficult
sports one of the most difficult games
you play because all these things that
you need to know about it has a lot to
do with business today I'm going to
share with you 15 points that you can
learn from the game of football that has
to with business and by the way if you
haven't yet subscribed to this channel
be sure to click on the subscribe button
to get future content and any other
videos that we have on the ITM let me
get to point number one you got to play
to the buzzer you'll watch many games
they'll play the wrong play coach makes
the wrong call it's game over they lose
and they didn't play to the buzzer they
didn't I managed it properly in business
in sales I've been in sales for many
many years I've run many sales
organizations and at the same time I've
done business what we're raising money
doing all this other stuff I've seen
people to often celebrate way too early
just because they got a sale and the
client said yes first it has to clear it
has to do this you need paperwork
verifications all of this other stuff
then you have a cooling-off period
because I ain't done yet you still got
work to do when it's done the money is
in the bank everything is done then you
can go out and say we finally have the
money and celebrate until then you got
to play to the buzzer number two always
communicate the game changes there's a
lot of audibles in football everyone's
calling audibles you'll hear them say
all these other stuff there's a lot of
audibles and the reason why I call
audibles and football is because you go
out you have this place so you know how
you say we're going to do this next okay
ready to go and you're going to line up
and say oh my gosh the defense knows
exactly what we're doing I got to call
inaudible so you call an audible
receiver comes over here you go from a
passing to a rush
you go from a rush to a passing you go
from whatever it could be right and you
make that adjustment if you communicate
and you play with your partners and your
salespeople and your team regularly you
know how to do you know how to make the
audible based on what the next thing we
need to do as a company what the next
investment we need to make what the next
hire the next fire the next whatever it
is that you need to do
because you're communicating number
three multiple teams defense often
special teams home office has sales
support compliance so many different
teams that you have every team if you
look their cheer each other on every
team so you'll hear many times special
team is pushing offense offense is
pushing defense defense is encouraging
offense sometimes a challenge say listen
man defense is doing their part brother
come on score some points often say hey
listen we're doing our part my defense
come on hold the fourth down right so
the company could be look we're making
our sales can you guys close and do your
operation well please look we're doing
the operation guys go get some new
clients but there's a little bit of push
going on but at the same time support
going on as well number four show love
to your supporters you'll see a lot of
players that are get up and they'll
thank their fans or you'll see teams
thinking they're fans I mean I can bring
that it back to myself
just earlier today we did a webinar let
me tell what this webinar was we're
putting an event together in Vegas here
soon and the event every year I put an
annual convention together this is a
million dollar budget convention top 100
thousand dollar a be dinner all this
other stuff we all these speakers Wayne
Gretzky Calipari Jobrani Fred all these
people that are going to be at this
event okay four five day event what I
did I want to rent at all the exotics in
Las Vegas nine Lambo six Ferraris ever
ended all the exotics we did a draft
pick right now in my top top twenty
performers from number one to number 20
it was a draft pick for one minute we
surprised them with the list of 20 cars
was because they didn't know the list of
20 cars with the price point out every
car color spite or not spite or whatever
it is cook
they picked whatever card they wanted
from top to bottom why am i doing that
they're the supporters of the company in
sports if you don't know who the
supporters of your company are which is
the fans you screw up you got to realize
what the supporters of your company are
in a football team people want to play
for the Patriots because they take care
of their players people want to play for
Dallas Cowboys because it takes the
other players you got to take care of
your supporters matter of fact Value
table why don't we do this year why
don't we do this year we're getting a
lot of people that are ordering value to
a value taemin and
snorts lately on value tainment store
you can always go and order your own
shirts on value Tama store comm but this
is what I'm going to do with anybody
that's watching so far right now stay
tuned to the end of the video I'm going
to have a special maybe we'll have a
special giveaway for some of the value
Tanner's that are on here stay tuned
till the end I'll make an announcement
on a giveaway they can take advantage of
but you gotta always show support you
got to show love to your supporters
number five surround yourself with
talent you know if you work in a place
and you're running a business and you
are the smartest guy there you're going
to be in trouble for a very long time if
you are the smartest guy for every
single thing you ain't going to go to
many places with your business if you
start a football team and you don't have
guys and you know in defense that have
talent and often some special teams you
can go too far you can't just sit on one
side by the way you got to really be
able to well run have a wall around the
team same goes with business as you
start starting you as you start
developing your business you got to
start saying who can I attract them my
side here to run sales who cannot
attract to do comply who can I attract
to do all this other stuff you got a
track talent talent isn't just sometimes
recruiting sometimes it's attracting you
got to do you got to create yourself in
an opportunity you attracting talent
that wants to also come and play for
your team because word spreads people
say when you work with this guy XYZ
happens when they work with you people
win number seven how to compete
competition sometimes it's a strange
thing you'll hear you'll hear a lot of
people say things about competition says
no one's my competition my body grant
will say I don't compete with anybody I
only want to dominate you'll hear in
books people say I don't compete with no
one competition is this competition is
that you're in the game of domination
all of those things are great for quotes
on Instagram believe me they work they
get a lot of likes but let me tell about
the game of competition if you play the
game of football and if you didn't watch
tape of your opponent if you didn't
study tapes of what the quarterback or
the quarterback were I need us to stuff
that you don't stand a chance to win the
championship now having said that your
best competition that you have in
business is to always focus on B
your own prior best as a team as a
company that's number one
90% of your focus should be on what you
can do to make your system better your
operation better your self better your
opportunity whether your company better
everything better here
10% should be spent studying your
competitors football teams don't spend
90% study in their competition
they spend 90% practice on working on
themselves the tempers I'm saying what
are the Patriots doing what are the
callable what all these other guys doing
you need to still spend some time on the
other side of the competition as well
number seven hard work battle we should
probably do video on a competition one
video specific to competition have some
thoughts we can do that number seven
hard work it's very simple yeah there's
so many debates and rhetoric that people
say I know a lot of people that work
hard and don't have a lot of I know a
lot of people that work hard I know a
lot of people that work hard in the game
of football you obviously got to have
some talent but there's a lot of
talented people in the world who are
athletic I see a lot of talented guys
who had a chance to play in the NFL and
they don't do it and I'm not even sum up
people get injured Paul got injured
heavily played college football or IO
Iowa State or IO which one did you play
football at Iowa okay and Paul got hurt
but there's a lot of guys who had a shot
at going in but they didn't have hard
work in the game of football if you
don't work hard
you ain't gonna last it for a long time
by the way in the game of business if
you don't work hard it's going to be in
a League of business for a long time it
requires your best effort and a constant
effort if you want to stay in the game
of business for a long time number eight
and by the way football some people are
in there for one year two years three
years very few people have a long career
takes a lot of work take care of your
body condition number eight study the
system and culture Paul was telling me
earlier I asked myself why do you think
footballs when the toughest I think
hockey's the toughest sport he says the
reason why footballs the toughest sport
because it has the most plays you got to
study often give me the different ones
dying for three three four I mean
there's so many things that you can say
in an offensive plays you have you know
what you can do option there's so much
detail to the game of football
accuracy there's so much to it right
but it requires you to study the system
every company every business every
industry no matter what you do there's a
system you've got a master the system
you've got a master the culture you got
to master that part of a game to be able
to scale it because a system is what
allows a player like me to come into a
system and the system I start
duplicating me to becoming a better
cornerback because the system that we
teach in a Belichick system the
quarterbacks do this I bring the talent
and my abilities whatever I have
but Belichick says here's how we do this
his quarterback coach has a system on
doing this his quarterback was exactly
the same thing that happens with your
business the more systems you have the
more talent you will duplicate number
nine practice obvious I don't need to
spend a lot of time on that you've got
to practice your trade constantly number
ten sacrifice you know that I know that
without sacrifice nothing's going to
happen to game of business if you don't
sacrifice number nine shortcuts you see
many times say PE D all this other stuff
and it's against the rules for you to do
in the game of football but it also
happens in a business whether it's
finances taxes laws regulation licensing
all of these things some people try to
shake take shortcuts I'm going to do it
this way with business I remember I was
in a Bally Total Fitness when I left
valleys there was a couple of us that we
were top salespeople on valleys and we
left valleys and when I left valleys one
of the guys wanted to complete different
business and a few years later was
making three four hundred thousand
dollars per month and I was only making
$30,000 a month after a couple years of
leaving the company and leaving Bally's
and I was furious this guy's making 400
I'm making 30 grand a month that's a big
difference what he makes in a month I
make in a year that's a big big
difference okay so I started saying man
maybe I need to do something and then
the more I started studying I realized
there's some shortcuts that's being
taken and I don't want to take shortcuts
so I stayed focused to my game my growth
was slightly slower than his but that
person just collapsed six million
dollars of IRS money being owed and all
of a sudden being asked to either go
back to your country because this
person's not a US citizen or stay here
and it was unfortunate one of the most
talented salespeople I saw
were the guy was a smooth closer but he
was always interested in this this
doesn't happen a world of business
neither does it happen a football number
never fewer change I'll tell you what I
mean by an ever fewer change people come
people go
companies hire or fire I'm in the
insurance industry every time I'm with a
new insurance company the executive team
changes their CEO just left this EVP
just left this president just left this
compliance guy just left this four it's
always changing so you got to be willing
to adapt football new players come and
go you got to be able to adapt as well
focus on your game improve your cell
bringing as much valuable solid
relationships and just keep growing and
bringing in value to your company and
the people that are working around you
number thirteen no pain no gain simple
as that
football the same thing in a game of
bass in the game of our business there
is no pain there is no gain nothing it
doesn't go you've got to make sure you
go through this part as well I'm always
confused when some people tell me and
say Pavel you don't sound how hard it is
for me you don't understand how hard it
is it's so difficult and a guy told me
the other day I don't know if I can do
this anymore it's so hard it's so
difficult I've been at it for a year and
a half I don't know if I can handle this
I said you have kids he says not so
you're married I said he says no I said
wait a minute
you're running the business you don't
have a wife you don't have kids you live
in with your mommy and daddy and you're
saying it's hard buddy what are you
going to do when you got a wife and kid
any got mortgage then you got all this
other stuff and you still gotta run your
business he says I never thought about
it that said that you don't have it hard
you have it easy put your head down get
to work eventually this will work out
for you we'll see what that guy's going
to do number fourteen play hurt every
time you talk to players when it's
playoff season they'll say things like
this what's the famous line Paul well
you know at this time you know everybody
in the NFL is hurt no one's playing with
perfectly and great conditions all of us
are run you know eighty percent right
now so we have to play they have
something with their fingers that's
crooked you know this guy's got some new
issues they put either there's always
something that's going on that's in
matter you still got to play her number
15 sometimes you're you know Joe Joe Joe
send it you have to work on Sunday
sometimes you have to work on Sundays I
had a guy that told me he says I don't
work on weekends I said really it's
interesting but you watch every single
football game on Sundays isn't it
amazing that your heroes work on
weekends he says what do you mean I said
you heroes work on weekends who are you
more heroes you always talk about your
past and you always talk about your foot
quarterback people work on Sundays but
you don't you watch them and that
amazing they're leaving you they work on
Sundays where you kick back sometimes
you've got to be willing to work on
Sundays sometimes I'm not saying all the
time but sometimes you got to be willing
to work on Sundays I'm a six-day week
guy but every once in a while I kind of
sneak in I like to get some work done on
Sundays as well and our last bonus one
that's the last bonus one I will tell
you okay if you stuck around if you
stuck around comment and said I stuck
around for the bonus round comment on
the bottom I stuck on to the bonus round
I promise you most people not stick
around for this bonus run and by the way
this is by far the most important point
out of all the points I'm going to make
to you right now watch this there is
psychological momentum in the world of
football last year patriots are playing
Atlanta Falcons we're at my house Paul
is next to me I've got a bunch of people
on my house we're over there everybody
saying it's game over we have this on
video I said listen I understand what
you're saying but you cannot bet against
the crazy guy like this this is not a
regular guy you don't say it's over with
this guy's that opposing quarterback he
says it's over then suddenly you see
they come out and Edelman says hey guys
we got this let's get this Afiya to
let's get this let's get this rating
comes poised will play play play play
play touchdown then they got this
two-point conversion they got this you
know they went and Julius Jones made
that one catch but then nothing happened
they were out of field goal range they
25 points then 25 points later than the
winning the Super Bowl
it's the biggest comeback in the history
of football what happened psychological
momentum Atlanta killed themselves
because you could tell they were all
stressed out psychologically the
momentum was going on the side of a
Brady and the Patriots and once
psychologically won that side it's game
over in business you'll have competitors
in business you'll have certain things
that's happening with your opponent that
if you're not too careful they can
psychologically make you believe you're
going to get your ass handed to you and
that's how they beat you so on one end
when that happens you
got to calm your nerves focus on your
game unfortunately only a percent or two
of people can really do that now make it
let me give the opposite side if you are
having psychological momentum you better
put your foot on the pedal man just
telling you right now when you get
psychological momentum you cannot stop a
single day when you have psychological
momentum I had a conversation just
yesterday I was in LA and I'll announced
you I just had a very big investment
that was made with a business partner
that's a pretty well-known business but
one of the most famous people around the
world you see who it is invested into
our company a big chunk of money I'll
tell you about it here in the next few
episodes I I come here one day I come
here on Monday when was it when I came
here was it on Monday or Tuesday when
did I come in here Monday I come song
Sunday I fly back from somewhere I don't
know where I'm on Sunday I fly like
where was I last week was when was it
known now before I lay I was somewhere
where I flew in so I fly back I get back
on Sunday and all of a sudden I'm not
feeling well something's going on my
body
my dad was in town and then I go to
sleep I wake up in the morning I didn't
sleep for 6 hours 6 hours my body
shaking I have to come to work it's
Monday morning I come to work I'm trying
to do everything I collapse and over
here I put two pillows I had two pillows
over here and there's a blanket here
that blanket right there can you give it
a blanket right there I'm laying on the
floor here okay I have this blanket I
asked Mari do we have a blanket you
bring it to me I take this is this your
blanket this is really your blanket this
thing smells by the way just so you know
there but it didn't matter
that's what of no idea what it is man so
I'm right here I take these to my couch
you know what he called those things the
bottom of them what he call those two
things pillows I don't know if you call
it a pillow seat cushion I take the seat
cushion I line it up right here and I
lay down I put my hands like this I can
walk I can't stand up so all of a sudden
like Suns going on so there are more
comes Tom comes a Jennifer comes what's
going on with you I'm laying down like
this I got up okay I said take me to the
emergency room I go to the emergency
room they give me a penicillin shot and
steroid shot and then they give me all
these antibiotics and I go the next day
Tuesday I have a flight to LA I had a
conference call early in the morning
then another conference call at 10
o'clock that goes an hour and half every
single week on Tuesdays then I get on a
flight to LA my body is shaking on the
flight I go in and I have two meeting in
Bakersfield and Baker still doesn't have
direct flight I surprised her
Bakersfield office we just signed a
6,000 square foot office space then I
Drive afterwards I have a meeting for
two hours with six of our executives in
Bakersfield to 12:30 from Bakersfield I
drive down to LA about a two-hour drive
nnn la I wake up go to appointment first
apartment five o'clock then we go 23
hours straight I work it was one of the
biggest business deals I've done in my
life you know why I did that
let me tell why I did that because I
understand the game of psychological
momentum fully understand a game of
psychological moment no one has any idea
what we're working on right now with
business but I understand this game I
fully understand this game and if you're
watching this if you're stuck in around
I don't know how long we are in this
video 21 minutes 19 minutes I don't know
the number if you're still around
watching this and you understand this
game of psychological momentum and if
you ever have it on your side and get
casual you're making a very big mistake
if you ever have it on your side you
keep going with it this is when suddenly
something massive happens that nobody
expected so do not take this thing for
granted nor let the stress side the
negative side of it make a small problem
seem like a big problem to you now I
told you earlier that I'm going to get
some of our supporters a gift here's
what I'm going to be doing we have a lot
of different value teaming shirts I'm an
entrepreneur shirts we're introducing
the whole new color and we're going to
have a new store I mean it's gonna be a
lot of real cool stuff that's going to
be introduced here soon so stay tuned
for that I'm going to give five I'm an
entrepreneur shirt to the first five
people first five people five of you who
go on my Instagram account
Patrick vid David Instagram is the first
five people on my Instagram account take
pay take any of the pics it doesn't
matter which one the pics it is tagged
five people and tell them why you
followed by your payment I'm going to
pick first five who post the comment
it's not five of you the first five who
do it so if you could do right now the
first five they do it you'll tell us
which
tripping over shirt you wanna you want
to imagine Johnson Laker version edition
you want the Mexican edition because we
have the Mexican colors the flag calls
you want the American doesn't matter
we will send one to you because without
you I wouldn't have the fire to keep
producing the content that we do on
value Tim and I am so busy right now
with my business and my family I simply
do it because I truly love the value
Tanner's out there who are fully
committed to grown their businesses and
creating jobs for everybody else so with
that being said thanks for watching take
the everybody provider
[Music]